right there's so much uncertainty right
now plenty of misinformation out there
so we're taking your questions straight
to our experts doing this every night
you can tweet us your questions too at
Fox News night providing your answers
tonight board-certified medical doctor
Jacqueline Nash Watts also part of the
Fox family now and chief medical officer
at heal dr. Renee do a thank you both
for giving us time tonight we appreciate
it thank you thank you all right we have
viewer questions but I have a couple of
other things that I keep commonly
getting asked so I want to ask you guys
about this dr. nasch wad first of all I
keep hearing people worried about
ibuprofen if they think they have flu if
they suspect they have kovat there are
worries and rumors all over Twitter that
if you take ibuprofen it can actually be
a negative thing do you know anything
about that what can you tell us yes so
there's actually no specific data or
studies to prove that this is true but
the thought is that if you take
ibuprofen it can actually allow for the
virus to enter the cell more easily
therefore it can make you more sick but
this hasn't been proven I think if you
take one dose or two dose it's not gonna
really make a huge difference but there
is an alternative which is acetaminophen
also known as Tylenol that can help
reduce fever in addition to drinking
lots of fluids staying hydrated is very
important to help reduce a fever and try
to get you feeling better okay
and so dr. doula we have heard if you do
have worries that this is that you have
an illness you maybe need to get tested
we're told don't show up at the ER call
your doctor's office but what about the
possibility of house cool house calls it
seems like an an old-school way of doing
things but other doctors who will
actually come see you is telemedicine an
option what's the best way to go sure so
we started a company called heal the the
company of which I'm a chief medical
officer and that's the entire idea if
you do have mild symptoms the best thing
to do is stay at home and presumably if
you're not feeling horribly you don't
need to be tested on the other hand if
you're feeling terribly you think you
need to be tested right now the the best
thing to do is to work with the
Department of Health to figure out where
to go to get testing we do deliver house
calls but what's been really interesting
about our house call delivery system is
first we have released telemedicine so
that we can deliver access to patients
but
there are plenty of people who have no
symptoms but they are diabetic they are
hypertensive they have anxiety or
depression which is especially
concerning at these crazy times
and so these house calls are actually
helping them get the access to care that
they need for their chronic disease so
that's been a really important piece of
what we're adding in our care model it's
such a personal thing and something that
I think would go a long way for people
like you said who have anxiety or are
trapped at home or they feel like they
shouldn't go out it's a good option have
okay so let's get to some viewer
questions here Nate Coggins says should
we be concerned about virus spreading on
newspapers including those delivered to
homes and businesses he for some reason
it says including the Wall Street
Journal I don't know why that one we'd
be more Germany than any others but the
fact is I think about this now bringing
the mail or bringing in packages dr.
nasch what do you say yes so it is
possible from viruses bacteria fungus to
live on inanimate objects so if you see
obvious debris then yes you want to
clean it off but really what's most
important is after handling a package or
something that's delivered to you or a
newspaper wash your hands that's the
number one way to prevent the spread of
infection and the best thing you can do
to protect yourself is just hand-washing
yeah so in overabundance of that we've
now had to buy a bunch of hand lotion -
because we're all washing much more
which is a good thing but now
everybody's that dried out scaly skin
okay if that's our worst problem we're
doing great okay clever Patriot tweets
this in if I need medical refills but
don't want to go to my physician what do
I do
doctor do what would you recommend so
this is a perfect reason to use our app
right book a visit use heal calm and
have either a house-call doctor come or
get a telemedicine visit for refills
okay simple you don't have to leave your
home you can check it out other ways or
call your doctors in fact we want you to
stay home yeah I think for right now
that's the best advice for just about
everybody who feels sick or has a
problem okay Linda gdg tweets hi Shannon
if a spouse test positive for kovat 19
and self-quarantine
should the other spouse remain home with
them my husband and I are the only ones
in the house and we're fine and healthy
at this time thanks dr. Nash white if
you have a positive test in the house
what should everybody else do yes that's
a great question and because Linda you
were exposed
to your husband you should also be in
quarantine as well and be careful you
still want to you know be not to over
infect other people that are in the
house that's a very common problem so
there could be you know kids in one room
parents in the other room and you can
infect one another so it's important to
all everyone be quarantined so we don't
spread from one person to another and
outside the family as well so if someone
is staying home they're ill but you're
helping tend to them you know is it just
a given that you may get infected should
both of you be wearing masks I mean
what's the best idea there it's tough
it's really tough especially if you know
you live in small quarters but if what
you want to do is if the person that's
sick that's definitely been diagnosed
yes they're the ones that should be
wearing a mask and then the person
that's taking care of them also has to
wear what's called PPE personal
protective equipment masks gowns gloves
and be changing it change it often as
well so that you're not you know
accidentally contaminating yourself okay
now Beth clardy tweets in are there any
home remedies that will help deter the
virus I've been reading that heat will
kill the virus such as deep breathing
and hot steam rooms your thoughts on
this please and thanks dr. doula I think
you know when when infection is
spreading you want to stay in a cool
clean dry climate right lots of hand
washing available hand sanitizer lots of
you know we're recommending six feet
apart from each other those are the
important steps to take to stop the
spread of infection and really quell its
transmission yeah I've heard some of
this too about whether if you're having
chest issues or you're suffering from
you know so any kind of respiratory
thing that if you can steam it out in a
hot shower that may be a good place to
open things up is that the case with the
Cova door no I don't think we're sure
yet right I think we're learning so much
about this virus every single day and
they do do that a lot for children for
example a humidifier will be set up and
certainly there's probably some
symptomatic relief but I think you have
to also be careful with humidifiers they
need to be cleaned properly right so for
that reason I'm suggesting the face mask
and the hand wash
the separation okay next up from Kelly
says what fever reducer should be used
for coronavirus ibuprofen - no alternate
tylenol and what so doctor Nashua you
had mentioned acetaminophen are there
other things is it just for now avoid
the ibuprofen what are the other options
I don't think if you take one or two
doses of ibuprofen that's really gonna
make it worse again there's no data or
science studies that show that that's
actually true but yes tylenol
acetaminophen and fluids can definitely
help reduce your temperature and and of
course rest and we again the biggest
issue is we don't want your illness to
be spread to other people so staying
home is a big one and just arresting so
that you're not overexerting your body
and not picking up other infections
because we do worry about secondary
bacterial infections as well yeah when
your body's already rundown okay Hayden
Hudson asked this I've heard rumors that
kovat 19 can cause kidney problems and
potential male reproductive problems any
truth to this doctor doula so with the
male reproduction there was some some
question about it and it's not been
proven with the kidney issues anytime a
patient gets severely ill and they can't
breathe well their blood pressure might
drop and then of course their kidneys
will suffer so this is a patient who
might even be in the ICU who needs
aggressive rehydration and theoretically
the vast majority of cases of patients
who have kovat are not this sick okay
and very quickly for either one of you
that would want to field this I've seen
a lot of chatter out there and stuff on
the web - about if we run low on these
ventilators there's some way that CPAP
machines that people with sleep apnea
and other issues used overnight could
possibly be used in a way that would in
some way provide some kind of ventilator
type benefit well possibly but we
actually would turn to old-fashioned
Ambu bags that we would use out and that
you know on the streets out you know in
the homes but hopefully we we don't get
to that point where we're using last
resort items and we're preparing now and
trying to prevent the spread of this
virus so that we're not going to have a
surge of patients requiring ventilator
breathing assistance all right doctor
Nashua doctor doula thank you so much
for both of your time and we're just
sending our prayers with you as you're
out there on the front lines thank you
so much